[Music]
and we're back haha another edition of
the Guru multiverse circle multiverse
yeah no more coins where are we going
with this well you know we painted
ourselves into a corner and that made us
strong because they say that there's
nothing stronger than a cornered animal
and now we're expanding in 360 degrees
I like multiverse yeah and think about
360 degrees which is one plane 360
degrees to the 360 the power of 360
which is all planes can you imagine what
that number is you tell me Yeah right
it's in the it's in the aliens that are
beyond anything we've ever said yes you
know not trillion quadrillion whatever
and my beard is growing longer with
every notice yeah Julie likes it I I
don't know how long did it take you to
grow that beard for your whole life
forever I've never shaved never shaved
No when was the last time you shaved
I didn't you never did no my beard
actually came in late so by the time my
beard was actually becoming a beard it
was my early 20s yeah so who gave a damn
about whether you shaved or not it was
my early 20s was in the middle 60s and
so you know I like beers were it and how
much hair do you have underneath that
turban this is all anybody ever asks you
that yeah of course they do this is all
balled up in here and the universe cut
that was just when I was when I was a
child
uh-huh but if you ever just let it let
it down at night yeah at home right yeah
so how long is it oh it's you know down
all the way down to the butt wherever on
my butt is yeah yeah it's a it's just
one of those things that you sort of get
used to not doing right it's it's the
convenience of not needing to deal with
that part of your world and then it just
makes it takes that out of out of
you know the decisions that you have to
make right taken care of
yeah you look at our closet and you know
there's a lot of white robes yeah it's
not like a big deal to determine what it
is but you rock the colors you always
you always you know you always have this
amazing combination of beautiful pastels
and you rock it well we are we are
expressive in our discipline yes
all right so today we're gonna talk
about the role of awareness in a world
of ignorance so what does that mean well
when I say in a world of ignorance I'm
not discrediting the world I'm
witnessing the world because the word
ignorance simply means to ignore and I
don't know if you've ever had a moment
in your house where you know people are
coming over and you notice oh my god it
the house is kind of a mess but you
hadn't noticed that the house was kind
of a mess because it was your mess and
so you were ignoring the fact that the
house was kind of a mess until you
thought about the people that you've
invited over for the evening and now
you're starting to see the house through
fresh eyes through their eyes and you're
going oh I'm gonna I gonna have to clean
the house up we're gonna have to fix the
house up and that's a little bit what's
happening in the world that people have
gotten so used to the world the way it
is that they're ignoring the
implications of the way it is mm-hmm
introduce yourself as a person of
awareness into that world that is
ignoring it and you look around and you
say wow there's a lot of things to clean
up around here and it's really what's
happening in this so-called debate about
you know the health of the world and the
health of the planet and you know etc
etc because those that are claiming that
there is no problem let's just put the
find the pedal to the metal and
accelerate industry
more they're ignoring the signs that
awareness is seeing they're ignoring
them so vehemently that when awareness
points it out ignorance says it's false
fact false news some conspiracy and so
what we are going to have to do as the
people of awareness and I know with your
with your plant-based diet and my
plant-based diet we have tremendous
amounts of awareness around food with
your exercise routine and our exercise
routine we have tremendous awareness
around bodily function but a person
that's just eating whatever and
lollygagging so to speak around in their
life they don't have those advantages
and so they can't see from that angle
what we're seeing so the response
ability on our side of that equation is
that we have to do two things point out
the problems very gently and that's not
what we're doing we're pointing out the
problems very aggressively and refer to
alternatives very actively it's the same
way as raising successful children if
you point out a children's inability is
very aggressively you'll stigmatize the
child but if you point out the the
inabilities very gently but more
energetically point out alternatives to
those abilities you will inspire the
child to seek those alternatives and
that's what I really feel we as human
beings conscious human beings need to
begin to do we need to get off the soap
boxes and saying you know we're going to
end tomorrow we can talk about that
between ourselves but in our public
voice we need to be able to say like for
example we were before we started
filming this moment we were talking
about some of the alternative burgers
right and what they've done is instead
of saying eating flesh food is bad
they've gone out and they've reproduced
the they've simulated the flesh food in
a plant-based way and they're becoming I
mean look at all the fast food
restaurants that are adopting rice
things so that's my point
yeah it's interesting I like that idea
of looking at for redefining ignorance
not through the lens of stupidity per se
but through ignoring but I think there's
a distinction or you have it yeah like
this is what I want to get into there's
a difference between willful ignorance
and on the one hand and on the other
hand somebody who simply doesn't know
better or hasn't been exposed to the
ideas that could break them out of that
perspective yeah
and willful ignorance is a harder one to
break because when you start tampering
with it you're tampering with that
willfulness and that willfulness has
produced an identity around that
ignorance which is very firmly held yeah
there's a big investment curt and
identity investments perfect word in
that idea mm-hmm and it becomes very
difficult to break the chains of that
and so pick your battles right
the idea of attracting through through a
loving attitude more willful attitude
toward awareness we will be able to
attract the more innocent then we will
be able to attract those who are
willfully ignorant who are staunchly
ignorant you know who are committed to
their abilities to ignore certain
aspects it's a it's also
we have to understand that once that
person starts down that willful path of
really ignoring and sticking to it
it becomes habitual so it reinforces
itself and in reinforcing itself it also
sets up sentries guards to watch for
anything that's trying to mess with that
attitude because it's a sense of
identity mm-hmm yeah I think it's
important to point out that on some
level I think all human beings are you
know willfully ignorant of one thing or
another and we're all you know creatures
that gravitate towards Norris or said
that about the world view like I think
the same could be that same bomb could
be levied at the plant-based community
like we're very invested in this idea
that this is an appropriate or favorable
way forward and we're resistant to any
anything that comes out that contravenes
that perspective right and the like I
tried my best to be objective and not
tribal but you know let's be honest like
I'm invested in this lifestyle it's a
way of and living for a long time I'm
convinced of its benefits and you know
the the health the health spectrum and
the environmental spectrum and from an
ethical point of view and I can feel my
own you know resistance rise up if
somebody challenges me on that and I
have to then step back and Marshall my
awareness in order to get into a place
of of listening and objectivity so you
know I want to be clear careful and
clear to not say like hey we're over
here on the good side and all these
other people are on the bad side I think
this is something that we all do to one
degree or another along the spectrum in
a variety of perspectives and and ideas
that we hold in Harbor if we are able to
invest in listening you use that word a
moment ago if we're able to invest in
listening we will be able to find
pathway in for more information to be
delivered until we reach that tipping
point in a person's awareness in which
they have one of those aha moments and
go wow I see now I see what you're
talking about and that only comes from
those of us who and let's let's remove
it from the right and the wrong but a
more sustainable you know a more ethical
more a less cruel you know cuz to
produce enough flesh food to feed seven
point seven billion people you got to
destroy lives in the millions every day
yeah without a doubt and to destroy
lives in the million every day it's got
to be a factory operation it's got to be
an automated operation and these are
lives that have been grazing in pastures
have been feeding in yards or in cages
or what-have-you
there's a lot of cruelty in that so how
do we dive into that ignorant and
shifted and the answer is gently and
slowly and through a lot of deep
listening which in sanskrit is called
Suniya a lot of this deep deep listening
so that we can find just a glint of an
avenue in i always look at the the
opposition of those who are heavily
invested in ignorance as energy and if
they're giving me this big big massive
pushback i appreciate i am grateful for
this energy and the moment i start
acting in that gratitude for the energy
of the force of their push back it calms
them a little bit too because they see
that they're not getting my reaction and
then all of a sudden we start to lower
the temperature of the
our conversation and it's a little bit
like I remember as it's young child
it's an odd metaphor but there was a
Western program called maverick and Bret
maverick and Bart maverick
and television show television yeah I
vaguely remember this and I mean you're
younger than yes so but it was it was my
growing up this show right and so one
time Bret maverick always had a thousand
dollar bill which was back in the day
when there was such a thing a thousand
dollar bill pinned pinned to the inside
of his lapel and somebody had stolen his
thousand dollar bill and he went to the
sheriff and the sheriff said you know
that's crazy everybody in this town is
honest and if you do anything wrong and
trying to get back your thousand dollar
bill it was kind of a setup against him
if you do anything wrong trying to get
your thousand dollar bill then we're
going to arrest you and so what he did
was he got a stick of wood and a knife
and he got a chair and he parked himself
on the porch of the sheriff's office for
the entire 60 minutes of the show or 30
minutes of the show and called on some
friends of his right he sent telegrams
to some frenzies and he sat there
whittling away and he would direct his
friends in this very sort of indirect
way as to how to investigate how to get
back his thousand dollar bill and it was
a beautiful example of the angles that
you have to use when combating willful
ignorance because willfully willful
ignorance is going to want to see you
fail they're gonna want to see you make
mistakes in your argument for a
plant-based diet for good exercise for
this for that for conscious mindful
meditation they're gonna want to see you
make mistakes and then they're going to
jump on those mistakes so you have to do
everything using that energy of
observation that they're giving you that
they're gifting you and work your way
through it kind of like just sitting on
that Sheriff
forge whittling away on something that
doesn't seem to be involved so that you
can get them to drop their guard enough
to expose what's going on and then
you'll find a pathway in it's a tough
one
yeah I mean right now what I see is a
lot of lecturing and shouting a lot of
professing a lot of tribalism like the
other the other day and and not a lot of
listening last month and I think that
listening really is the key and I think
that there is an epidemic right now of
people who are lonely and disconnected
and in a state of varying degrees of
desperation and how they live and the
internet whether it's Twitter or
what-have-you is a is a is an outlet for
that frustration but ultimately if you
can see past that you can develop a
level of empathy and awareness that this
is a person who if somebody's lashing
out all the time this is a person who is
in pain this is a person who is
suffering and fundamentally this is a
person who is just desperate to be heard
right and if you can be available to
hear that person if you can suspend your
judgement and be present for that
person's perspective even if you
disagree with it then you have a chance
at true connection and through that true
connection can come can can that can
create a dialogue that can be productive
but it's a two-way street and it I think
it requires you know a lot of a lot of
awareness and patience to be able to
navigate without falling prey to like I
know for myself like I want to lash out
to what I want to I get defensive and I
get angry and all of these emotions are
swirling around to be able to kind of
set that all aside and just
like be present for another human being
to let them know like I see you and I
hear you mm-hmm even if I totally
disagree with you
or I think what you're saying is you
know ignorant or wrongheaded to validate
the humanity in that person I think is
fundamental to trying to create the
change that you want to see in the world
or even setting that aside because that
to me that kind of comes off as
pretentious to really just without
agenda if I can just connect with this
other human being that's it that's a win
regardless of anything else that might
transpire out of that exchange you use
the word patience and in the in the
ancient teachings the masters would
oftentimes call patience as how much
time have you placed in the imagined
trajectory so if you imagine that
something has to be changed by this date
then that's going to stimulate the
amount of tolerance that you have within
that period of time but if you extend
that you may actually finish before this
previously stated date but you've
extended the amount of time that you're
going to allow something to be completed
and therefore you're much more relaxed
within each moment of the completion and
when you relax down as that highly aware
being dealing with ignorance whether
it's willful or just you know
unintentional you're actually in a
relaxed state which you've said and in
that you can find that agenda free
commonality I'll find it quite
interesting going to gatherings you know
large gatherings where there are people
of all different varieties and what I
end up doing is I'll end up having a
conversation with someone and and
they'll usually come in and start
talking okay why do you look like this
and why do you
what do you do what is the whole thing
and I have found over the decades that
if I take that let's call it bait and
start talking eventually we're going to
get into discrepancies because what I'm
going to be saying is not going to be
coinciding with what there are you
accustomed to so what I'll usually do is
I'll say a few words about what they've
asked and then immediately turn it
around to them and let them express
themselves and I find that eventually
I'll be able to interject enough of what
it is to be me that they'll have a
better understanding of who I am and
what I'm about than if I had actually
just you know maintained a monologue and
explained to them in detail what it is
to be a yogi and a meditator and a vegan
and on and on and on and a musician etc
and so that's what I find is that you
have to if you're aware you have to
always apply your awareness and if
you're claiming to be aware and you're
applying your awareness you will find
those little moments in which you can
interject a plant-based
comment an exercise or a meditation
based comment and you can put it in
words that they'll understand rather
than words that are more inclined
towards people of your understanding hmm
yeah I think that it's delicate and it
does require patience a long-running
yeah a long runway but then I start to
think about let's use let's use global
climate change as an example there are
certain scientists that say we have a
hundred years left if we continue along
this path or 50 year or whatever it is
like there's varying degrees of opinions
on this and they're accelerating yes but
let's just agree for the purposes of
argument and conversation
you know we have a limited window of
time here in order to solve massive
problems and that then truncates that
runway and with a truncated runway and
less time that heightens the
emotionality of the argument because
without patience we then are feeling
compelled that we have to change minds
rapidly and then we descend into this
strategy or tactics that are actually
working at cross-purposes with that goal
that we're trying to achieve yeah that's
why I say if you extend the runway even
though you know that it's beyond the
time limits that science is setting
everyone relaxes and in that relaxation
we can hit that that point that tipping
point much more rapidly for example in a
petri dish as bacteria is forming it
takes 95% of the time of the total
experiment to fill 50% of the petri dish
but based on the conditions of scale the
last 50 percentage is doubling it's just
overnight and so 50% is filled in 95%
and the rest is filled in a miniscule
amount of the remainder of the
experiment and the same thing could hold
true as we are more relaxed as we are
more patient by by the way patience is
defined in Sanskrit not as waiting but
as knowing the outcome and when you know
the outcome you are very patient you are
very methodical you're very intentional
you're very purposeful and when you're
methodical intentional and purposeful
and you're loving and gentle you can get
things put in place very specifically
and very effectively without having to
force people into it
this and this is the new attitude that
we'll have to right now we're just sort
of reminiscing in the spoils of old
attitudes the right going against the
wrong right and everyone intensifying
and creating a screaming contest those
of us who are really going to make the
difference and I include all of us that
are listening to these podcasts because
the inquisitive mind is the is the
beautiful mind those of us that are
going to make the difference if we take
a half step back and then start to
produce okay I know the outcome is going
to be one of success I can go to my
death knowing that I can go to the
disaster of the world knowing that but
I'll be more effective between now and
then if I know this for a fact if I
believe this absolutely and I'll be
effective now all I have to do is get
more people to have that attitude and
really we can change the world with
about a few tens of millions of people
with that attitude and I think that what
we're looking at in a world of awareness
dealing with ignorance is that the onus
is upon the awareness not the ignorance
we're all saying that they're the ones
that are destroying the world well the
world is being destroyed with whatever
is causing it were the ones that are
going to save it and so rather than
spending any energy claiming that
they're the ones destroying it let's
invest all of our energy into as the
military would talk about let's not
build a greater punch through the middle
let's outflank right let's come around
and surround you know that this problem
because this problem is huge I mean life
is not going to be expelled in the
universe in the multiverse because life
is every life is all over the place but
if this planet dies in its ability to
sustain life and human life on our watch
when we go back to the home office after
this assignment we're gonna be in deep
[ __ ] I'm so fired man yeah yeah well we
should have been fired a long time ago
based upon our performance I you know
I've been we were talking before the
podcast like I you asked me like if I've
been traveling and I was like yeah I've
been a minute like I'm crazy
travel recently yeah well just given me
the ability to be around a lot of
different kinds of people and then a lot
of airports and a lot of gazing down
from you know 7,000 feet or whatever it
is you know on planet earth and I just
kept thinking like everywhere I go
people have just taken over the planet
and have and have literally made it
their domicile like every nook and
cranny of it which is kind of an amazing
thing but then I think I don't think
that's so good when you see a nice shot
of from space a planet Earth and you see
all that light all that electricity
illuminating all that amount of sky and
you think and then you landing into an
airport and you see all this massive
buildings and roads and structure
unreal we may have to tone it down a bit
a little bit you think couldn't be the
craziest thing is is when you're
descending into Los Angeles when you fly
over LA like I've never seen sprawl like
we have here there's this never-ending
grid of humanity that like that is just
you know laced itself like this matrix
on the crust of planet Earth consuming
it at an you know a remarkable
unsustainable rate and it is that petri
dish like we are filling the petri dish
right now and there's only so much left
and you know whether humanity makes it
or not remains to be seen I'm interested
in how you get to this place of knowing
but I have no doubt that life will
prevail
on planet Earth and beyond I think it's
more a question of whether humanity is
going to be able to make it work without
having to dig caves and go underground
well that may come you know we may have
to alter dramatically I mean I don't
know if we've covered this but on one of
our podcasts together but there's this
thing called the equatorial bulge and
the equatorial bulge is caused by the
spinning of the planet the equator spins
faster than the places closer to the
poles it's just like when you're on one
of those spinning things in a playground
if you get closer to the center you're
spinning less rapidly than if you're on
the edge and so that centrifugal force
at this at the equator of the planet has
thrown the oceans up to a level of 481
feet higher and it's 1,500 miles wide
well that's a massive amount of water
and what happens is not that just the
ice melt from the ice caps and Greenland
is going to you know cause the oceans to
rise but these waves these chunks of
this equatorial bulge when the planet
gets a different nature to its spin
start to break off and these then become
these massive massive tsunamis so
there's a lot going on that we haven't
even begun to construct in our
imagination fires earthquakes your
displacement and the shifting of the
tectonic plates the displacement of the
ice and how that causes tectonic plates
shifter
earthquakes droughts they say that India
that 80% of India will start will begin
desert death certification in 20 years
80% of India which has been the
breadbasket of Asia and so what we have
going on here is this awareness which is
intensifying our need to make it
different and we've got to have a
meditative attitude not that everything
is going to be okay no but I know that
it'll be okay
if we accelerate the awareness in this
many people and we can't spend any of
our energy in my estimation we can't
spend any of our energy attacking the
core of the problem mm-hmm we have to
like I was saying outflank it we have to
spend our energy outflanking the problem
with those who have an innocence rather
than a willful ignorance those who have
an innocent ignorant that it are more
able to be cultivated into a new way of
thinking and I'll tell you if we get
enough people to be successful in their
life in their health living longer
living healthier because of plant-based
diet if we get enough people who are
more intuitive because of their mindful
and meditative practices all of a sudden
by that very nature of if you see
something you like you're going to want
it if you see health you're going to
want it if you see intuitive nature's
you're going to want it that's how we
outflank the problem hmm what about the
idea that maybe we're not supposed to
make it like what if we reserved Jones
really yeah like what if we what if we
take away our judgment on on you know
the the the goodness of humanity and our
prospects for survival like and and and
instead entertain the idea that much
like the caterpillar and the butterfly
or the tadpole in the Frog that we are
here to birth a new type of
consciousness that we're now seeing
emerging in the form of AI and that our
entire purpose as human beings who are
who are driven to constantly innovate
and innovate and innovate and advance
and grow that this is all one big macro
organism stage-play crafted and created
simply to give
to a new type of intelligence and life
and consciousness in the form of these
technological entities that are now
starting to gestate yeah that you know I
am very open-minded about this in
addition you know so I said meant my
brain and there's a part of my brain
that remains open to that idea because I
don't want to deny it because I want to
remain I want to I want to test it and
then there's another part of my my
awareness that says okay let's focus on
ways of creatively achieving a
benevolent outcome and then there's
another part of my brain that goes into
this form of when you think about a
single-celled animal getting together
with another single-celled animal in the
early stages of the world biology and
botany it was called the you know the
multi the multi-celled animal that every
one of the cells did its did everything
right would they were colony of cells
and then eventually that evolved into
the colonies specializing in certain
areas and in one form to stomach and
another form to brain in another form
and all and now we're living in that
biology and maybe you know not maybe
it's not AI and maybe it's not just
saving the planet but maybe it's that
there's a collective that is the next
stage of that collective that is all of
us working together which is really a
peaceful operation because the majority
of our body likes the rest of our body
our heart doesn't fight our fingers and
our fingers don't fight our liver etc
and so when we recognize ourselves as
the body of life which is what
plant-based living often
as in that you know the cows are as
important as the humans as important as
the pigs are and we think about
consciousness in the non-local nature of
consciousness and I look in you know I
came in and the first animal to greet me
today at your house was where you're -
what are their their breed Great
Pyrenees
the Great Pyrenees I mean these massive
dogs and I just came from a household
and our massive dogs are three
chihuahuas you know and the these
creatures have their own languaging and
for us to differentiate and say ours is
superior is ignorant and my awareness
when I approached your Great Pyrenees is
that Wow they have this whole world
happening which can interface with my
world if I'll take and slow mind down
right so maybe AI has the answer
maybe just all going plant-based in you
know doing you know recyclable and and
sustainable is the answer or maybe
there's this whole other way in which we
all start to serve each other in life in
love hmm
so there's so much going on right now
and we're at the threshold so paint that
utopian picture for me it acts like the
heart center which is made up of the
lungs and the heart and the thymus gland
and the nature of the heart center is
that the lungs at rest are full of air a
collapsed lung is an oddity the heart at
rest is full of blood
it gives effort to serve the body and
then it surrenders and the body floods
it back with blood and if we were to
literally 180 degrees switch our
attitude very much like the sobriety
world in which
being of service is a very high ideal is
a very high value being of service and
so if the early stages of this utopian
world are simply turning the table from
how can I get to how can I serve that in
and of itself will create a surge of
opportunity for us to be able to take
care of each other's needs and in doing
so all of our needs are going to all to
ultimately be taken care of as well yeah
I think in order to achieve that we have
to erect systemic changes because our
incentives are misaligned with that
ideology in that the structures that
form our society in our culture create
massive incentives for us to to be
people who go out into the world and try
to extract learn to get and when we are
not only encouraged to do that we are
handsomely rewarded for doing that how
can we create political and cultural
systems that counteract that or provide
healthier incentives that encourage us
to serve and to be selfless and to
embrace the macrocosm over the you know
selfish wants and desires of sort of
serving ourselves kind of like inside of
our body we have unfriendly and friendly
bacteria you know the unfriendly
bacteria are the bacteria that are
depleting our strengths and the friendly
bacterias are the bacterias that assist
our efforts they assist our digestion
they assist other things too
I look at it again in the petri dish
you know scenario let's become the
friendly bacteria let's become the
bacteria
that spreads over time by demonstrating
how all your needs are met as long as
you're of service to others and this
idea of you know God and this and that
and then there's the atheist we talked
about that off off camera you know we
don't even we don't even get into that
because we get into the whole ism of
life and how what's good for one aspect
of life is is going to be good for all
life and what's good for the forest is
good for the animals so let's keep the
forest and let's stop destroying the
amount of forest that we're doing for
the sake of raising animals for killing
and slaughtering and eating and let's
really start to demonstrate in large
swaths you know let's paint large
pictures of ways in which in a very
non-attacking way not attacking the
ignorance but displaying the awareness
because people can have ah ha moments
that change their world I can remember
back in the early days of computers
having an aha moment around ms-dos when
I finally figure how you I don't know if
you remember but you Mac users never had
to really deal with it but us PC users
you had to type in all these things just
to get it to do one little thing for it
to boot up all the code yeah and when I
had an aha moment of what I was actually
doing that's when it started to make
sense to me and one that happened in one
small little way many other things there
was a domino effect many other things
started to make a great deal of sense to
me that's what I'm looking for I'm
looking for awareness producing the
potential of aha yeah well I certainly
subscribe to the idea that living a life
of service is
is the optimal path for fulfillment and
blazing a purposeful life and also for
making sure that your needs are met and
it's a weird spiritual conundrum then
contravenes our Western you know
everything Western about the way that we
live and and and think in the sense that
rather than going out and trying to
extract and get and maximize your income
by freely giving yourself in service to
others is actually the way to make sure
that your cup runneth over
mmm-hmm I don't know why this works but
I found it to be universal law but as
you're explaining you know this idea I
couldn't help but think you know to sort
of empathize or put myself in the shoes
of somebody who might be listening who's
thinking that's great
like I understand what you're saying and
I even intellectually you know perhaps
agree with it but I'm working two jobs
I'm a single mom you know I I just you
know I don't have time to entertain you
know don't like wax rhapsodic about this
idealized utopian world because I'm just
struggling to put food on the table and
my options are limited so I would say to
the single mom single father working two
jobs to make ends meet three jobs to
make ends meet that in amongst all of
that you must set aside five minutes in
which you very consciously sit down and
do nothing just breathe five minutes
three minutes if you get successful with
three to five there will be some
mornings that you want to extend it to
seven or eleven or fifteen and then all
of a sudden it will become as important
to you
as putting food on the table and then
out of those seven minutes 10 minutes 15
minutes whatever it becomes all of a
sudden ideas will start to enter in
ideas of how you can do more for less
and what you've actually been doing is
you've been of service and the first
person that you have to be of service to
is yourself
mm-hm and so by being of service to
yourself you will start to gain a little
bit of you know balance and and
equanimity and you will start to push
out that which is pressing in on you all
of those bills all of those
responsibilities and you'll start to
push out and you will start to learn how
to this an old cliche but you'll start
to learn how to work smarter rather than
harder mmm and it's not going to come in
this again you know give yourself enough
runway it's not going to come you know
like in 30 days we're not talking about
okay money-back guarantee in 30 days you
get you know bubble no it might take a
year it might take a couple of years but
in amongst those moments that if you
have gifted to yourself in which nothing
is going to interfere with being of
service to yourself in those moments
some ideas are going to come up some
connections are going to come up some I
need to call so and so is going to come
up and in making that phone call so and
so is going to say hey did you know what
I'm in looking for someone that could do
exactly this and all of a sudden year
two or three jobs gets reduced down to
one job because you have some kind of
integrity and quality because if you're
working two to three jobs you've got a
lot of responsibilities you've got a lot
of integrity you've got a lot of really
good qualities and there are people all
over the world that are looking for
those qualities there's a lot of truth
in that and I couldn't help but reflect
upon my own path and experience my own
process
dating back
twenty years at this point like it is a
long game who was it who said something
along the lines of man's suffering is
directly related to his inability to be
alone with his thoughts like speaking to
the difficulty that we all have just
that you're proposing this idea of like
let's just sit for five minutes that
Viktor Frankl I think I think it is I
think that's right yeah and I didn't get
that quote exactly right but that's that
was criminal sentiment yeah we're so
resistant you you say five minutes it
sounds so accessible and you're like we
fight that like I don't have five
minutes or when that five minutes arises
we'll come up with an excuse to not do
it and you know in truth my experience
as imperfect as it has been you know
began with getting sober twenty years
ago and it started with that five
minutes or that one page of journaling
and you know it took a very very long
time to arrive at this place and to draw
it back to the petri dish analogy for
years there was no indicia of any
progress whatsoever because those cells
dividing you know one by one don't seem
to make a discernible difference and
then one day you know there's an there's
enough mass where the the subsequent
division is meaningful but you have to
be willing to put in all of that time
all of that you know effort and
diligence in anonymity to wrestle with
you know who it is that you are and who
it is that you want to be and exploiting
those those instincts as they arise one
by one before anything is tangibly
perceptible in terms of how your life
has changed and what started this
segment of our conversation here was you
saying what about the person be it a man
or a woman who's working multiple jobs
trying to make ends meet
already the qualities that that person
person should recognize in themselves
are the qualities of a ability to
respond which is responsibility
integrity dedication love because
they're doing it to support certain
fundamental aspects of life so the
qualities are already there I don't
think that we're going to be effective
in changing the indolence the ones that
are just living in in you know dire
conditions that are not thinking that
there's any way through those will be
inspired by the ones that we inspire
it's sort of a it's sort of a
multi-level multi-level marketing
routine in that you know we can inspire
those that are already putting forth
great effort by just saying take a
section of time out very small to begin
with and let it expand by an but in and
of itself so that you can apply those
same tendencies of diligence and
dedication and devotion and
responsibility and integrity you can
apply it to just sitting and breathing
and noticing your world noticing your
relationship with people around you the
people that you work with noticing the
way in which you interact noticing the
way you interact with yourself one salad
somebody once said that if if we had a
friend that treats us like we treat
ourselves we wouldn't have that friend
right and you know so what we have to be
able to do is just give ourselves that
little tiny piece and let it expand like
the bacteria in the petri dish if
somebody's listening to this and it's
their first exposure to such a practice
is there any kind of technique that
people can bear in mind or utilize if
they have that five minute window yeah
if they if they if they
command that five-minute window right
not demand but command that five minute
window then just sit comfortably you
could sit in your car in the parking lot
before you go into your office or your
place of work and close your eyes so
that the optics don't distract you of
what's going on around you if you're
self-conscious and you don't want to be
seen in your car with your eyes closed
then do it before you get out of your
garage or do it before you get into your
car but just close your eyes and begin
to breathe in through the nose and be
very aware of your breathing and then
just blow out through your mouth as if
you're blowing through your lips as if
you're blowing out a single candle and
because the difference between inhale
and exhale is nose to mouth it's going
to start triggering an awareness an
awareness of some differences and so you
inhale and you exhale and you inhale and
you exhale and so that's taken care of
the upper body in the lower body in the
belly in the abdominal area and what you
want to do is when you inhale you want
to push your belly out and let your
diaphragm drop and what this will do is
this will create more volume in your
lungs and you'll be able to take a
deeper breath it's like what singers do
when they learn how to sing from their
gut and so you push the belly out and
you inhale and then you pull the belly
in as you blow out through your mouth
and literally after three minutes you're
going to be noticing you're a little bit
less frenzied you're a lot less anxious
and you're starting to breed
quiescence this calmness now the moment
you engage life it's going to go away
the next day you do it the moment you
engage life it's going to remain with
you for a nanosecond the third day you
do it the moment you engage life it's
going to remain with you for two
nanoseconds right and as you keep doing
it over and over day in and day out all
of a sudden you will find that after
doing your meditation after doing your
contemplation whatever you want to call
it mindfulness whatever you want to call
it you extend the amount of time that it
takes for the rummaging z' of the world
to get back on your shoulders and drive
your buggy and eventually after doing it
consistently for a few weeks
sort of a round figure is six weeks
after you've done this for six weeks
you're going to notice that which you
just spoke about a moment ago and that
is that you know the number of cells
that activate are not really noticeable
the number of the amount of change that
you're creating is not really noticeable
until it is those of you that cut your
hair you don't notice you need a haircut
until you do right yeah I think that
that the common experience is that the
change remains unnoticeable within the
self but noticeable to others so the
first indication that that that you have
made some level of shift will be made
aware to you by somebody else you won't
you won't see it in yourself but
somebody will reflect it back to you and
you'll be like really oh yeah you seem
different or you seem more grounded it
really hurt press ENTER yeah yeah hey
what do you do yeah during these periods
of meditation or whatever you want to
whatever nomenclature you want to attach
to it I'm interested in and in your
technique for dealing with thoughts as
they arise so the way that I've been
taught and the way that I kind of deal
with this is to not have a judge like
you
the common the common conventional
wisdom is I can't meditate because my
mind's attacking me it's too busy so I
can't do it but that's the nature of the
mind and the idea is to notice those
thoughts when they arise and then gently
and without judgment try to return your
attention to the breath or whatever
technique that you're using to try to
get into that state of no-mind which you
may experience for a nanosecond you're
lucky if you get two seconds of that
before the next idea pops into your mind
and it's a constant process of trying to
move past the thinking mind in a gentle
way so how do you think about dealing
with the mind as these thoughts arise or
you know the the attacking of thoughts
that are invading this space that you're
trying to carve out as as you know
peaceful and sort of idea free or is
that totally ask ants from the way that
you think and look at this once again as
you do it more consistently you form a
new habit the the the brain introducing
thought is a habit and it hasn't been
managed for how every many years you
have been living and when you start a
practice of meditation you're starting
literally a practice of changing a habit
and the more aggressively you try to
change a habit the more aggressively the
habit will resist your change and that's
why what the way you described it was
very beautiful and that you you know you
gently coax your focus back to the
breath or whatever it is that you're
that you're focusing on
so you know a lot of times people say oh
that's that stuff I'm a Christian or
that's that stuff I'm a Muslim you know
I can't do that because that's not
Christian I said no this is this if
you're a Christian then when your mind
starts to wander bring Jesus in or bring
Mary in or bring you know Jesus loving
nature in or bring something out of the
Bible and just replace it and let that
be the way in which you segue if you're
Muslim the same thing holds true just
bring the stories from the Quran bring
in the ideals of the values of your
faith and so this is not about having a
way of faith this is about having a way
of using your faith to enhance your
meditative process to calm down the
inquisitive the persistency of thought
and allow you to get a broader
perspective because the thought is just
this noise that's right there in front
of you and when you can relax the habit
of that noise you see beyond that you
can see beyond let's use cliche you can
see beyond the horizon of your noise and
in that seeing beyond or hearing beyond
or feeling beyond whatever it is for you
you end up beginning to have new ideas
new concepts new thoughts of wow I could
do this this way I remember one time
back in the early 80s I was running a
business for for the organization that
that promotes Kundalini Yoga is taught
by Yogi Bhajan
and we were in the middle of the 1980
collapse of the economy the the interest
levels were at like prime level was at
18% you could have a CD that make more
money than you could make right right
and not a CD that you play but a certain
deposit yeah I knew you did that I was
just making sure the audience and I went
to yoga budget and I said you know these
major stores that are buying our
products are not selling it and so
they're [ __ ] they're damaging it and
shipping it back to us and claiming that
it was damaged in shipment and I said I
have no I have no response for that I
have no way of getting around it and he
said I want you to meditate on this
particular breaths style and come back
to me in five months I thought oh my god
this is insane I'm gonna be bankrupt in
30 days but I wasn't bankrupt in 30 days
by focusing on this meditation this
thing that I was doing every single day
ideas were starting to come into my head
new ideas that I hadn't ever thought of
and eventually not five months down the
road but about three months down the
road much sooner you know I went back to
yoga budget and I said hey I've come up
with this crazy idea and he said great
go to the lawyers go to the lawyer go to
the accountant tell them what your ideas
tell me what'd they say went to both of
them they said that's the worst idea in
the world it's gonna fail
don't go there you'll get sued bla bla
bla bla bla bla I went back to a yoga
budget and he said perfect prove them
wrong because it came to you out of that
being able to see beyond the noise so
let's value that and let's act on that
and let's see let's see if all those bad
things happen and I'll tell you that
within nine months we had turned the
whole business around we were making
instead of making
minuscule profits on the bottom line we
were making significant profits on the
bottom line and what we did was we just
took it from being a manufacturer
wholesale to being a manufacturer of
direct to retail mm-hmm and the whole
world opened up it's not about the
specifics of the moment it's about the
fact that when you reduce the noise of
the constant chatter which being
responsible being full of integrity will
increase that noise not that it's bad
but you just have a really strong
attitude towards life but by relaxing
that for a few moments every day you'll
be able to catch glimpses of a future
that has possibilities yeah I think that
that's a beautiful story and very
illustrative that's what I think's in
sobriety isn't it
you catch glimpses of what a sober life
is like yes over time and you accumulate
those beads and you draw inspiration
from the people around you that are
living their lives in a manner that you
would like to and you know you it's a
yeah it's a it's a long drawn-out it's
slow Briah tea it's a long drawn-out
process but I like that word oh you
hadn't heard that one before slow
variety I'm nice but what I was going to
say was even the incessant chatter of
the thinking mind is instructive because
if you're new to this practice and your
brain is attacking you understand that
this is the low background hum of your
life that is going on all the time and
the more awareness that you can draw to
that you become more consciously aware
the extent to which that thing that's
running in the background that you
seemingly don't feel like you have any
domain or control over is dictating how
you respond and react to the world and
driving your decision tree and
ultimately the actions that you take so
that in and of itself is like a grand
Epiphany that should then essentially
prove to you how much this practice is
needed to quell that voice
so that you can start to get the upper
hand on how your brain is functioning so
that you can reprogram it to create
better decision trees and less reactive
modalities for how you interact with the
world well you know a moment ago we were
talking about influencing the world you
know and the world is aggressive and
influencing and one of the greatest
things to be able to influence is to sit
down and actually listen so that you can
find the way in so is you're talking I'm
thinking as you're talking I'm thinking
these thoughts are suggestions right
there your brain reaching out there for
answers and solutions and they're coming
up with all of these crazy ideas not all
of which are going to be crazy but
you're not usually listening to them and
so what the earliest stages of
meditation are is just shutting them up
right in this way and actually listening
to what's going on in what you just said
the background in the background sound
and when you start to listen to this
every once in a while you'll hear a
pattern repeat and a pattern you'll
think oh my gosh maybe that's a good
idea
and you'll write it down by the way I
highly suggest that in your 5 minutes in
year 3 or 7 whatever the amount is that
you're going to set aside for yourself
to do this practice keep a notebook and
a pen or pencil and be able to don't do
it digitally be able to write these
ideas down because eventually what
happens is your brain starts to drop
into what's called alpha and theta mode
in meditation and that's the theta mode
is the same as your dream time only
you're consciously dreaming in this mode
and you will come up with ideas they
won't all be you know earth-shattering
but there'll be different kinds of ideas
and you need to write those down because
if you don't you'll forget them
my experience is that that background
hum I think this is the experience for a
lot of people is a lot of negative
reinforcement it's never going to work
out they're gonna figure out that you
don't know what you're doing this isn't
worth doing like you know it's it's it's
a constant loop of negative thought
patterns self defeatism fear anxiety
like all of these all of these impulses
that are however you know deeply
ingrained in me are you know programmed
there and they'll where the initial
awareness before the good ideas come in
is just recognizing like wow this is
like what I'm telling myself all day
long goes back to what you were saying
earlier about you know you would never
maintain a friendship with somebody who
talks about the way you talk to yourself
yeah so for me the first phase of this
whole thing is is is acknowledging that
this is what's going on in the
background then it becomes about
deconstructing it to understand that you
know this is you know what do they say
fear is is as facts not in evidence
appearing real like hey is this really
real like I'm creating my reality out of
out of this tape that's playing in the
background but that that tape
necessarily isn't rooted in reality I
can create a new story and try to build
a better healthier foundation for the
tape that gets played in the background
or to stop the tape altogether and
that's when you start to see glimpses of
those new or better ideas starting to
percolate up yeah and there's an there
is a great master that once said if when
you begin meditating all hell doesn't
break loose in your brain then you're
not meditating and that is that it's
always going on in the brain and the
brain mind connection when you start
meditating you start paying attention to
it and that's why it seems to be so
overwhelming the moment you start paying
attention to it it's like a child if you
pay attention to a child it will stop
ultimately it will stop disrupting you
too
trying to get your attention because it
knows it can easily get your attention
if it just comes and pulls on your shirt
or something and that's the way thoughts
are thoughts are like little children
they're always trying to bombard you
with their importance and if you can
turn to them and listen to them and go
into them and take time with them all of
a sudden they don't feel like they have
to attack you and bombard you hmm
and that's when mindfulness meditation
whatever you want to call it that's when
it starts to become effective and one of
the things that I find to be very good
is that when you are treating yourself
poorly you know when you when you go oh
my god is this what I is this what's
going on in my brain mind connection all
day and I'm just not aware of it I'm
just not paying attention am I'm
ignoring it you know bring in your
heroes if if Lord Buddha is your hero of
Jesus is your hero from Mohammed is your
hero of guru nanak guru gobind saying if
if Lord Krishna if if aunt Charl if aunt
Harriet and uncle Charlie are your
heroes whoever they are people that you
have great respect for our iconic beings
that you've heard great stories about
they may not be true stories but they're
inspiring stories you know like the like
the ancient scriptures they're not
necessarily all true some of them are
more symbolic let those also wash over
you mindfully reach out and bring those
into the equation bring those into the
sound current and that's one of the
reasons why we also use what's called
mantra which are just basically sounds
and syllables and so sometimes I have
found that if I use long vowel syllables
like oo or like ma that I can slow down
the jagged nature of the thought attacks
so if I'm inhaling through my nose
and I'll exhale through a
[Music]
and just keep it going and going and
going and going what I'm actually doing
is I'm opening a like a doctor says say
ah
Willem ah is like an ah and you're
opening the throat you're opening the
eustachian tubes you're opening up all
of this mechanism that is actually
resonating with your thought patterns
it's actually you hear in the inner ear
your thoughts your thoughts are often in
the same voice that you speak with but
just a different kind of different tonal
quality and so using sound using breath
using all of these various techniques
and technologies is very Christian is
very Buddhist is very Hindu is very is
Lama is very Sikh is very Hardy Astron
is very whatever you want to say because
80s atheist perfect people get freaked
out with mantras though people start to
feel now with mantras only because it's
a habit to get freaked out with mantras
and it's a common fear to get freaked
out with mantras but you know people
used to get freaked out with all kinds
of things including flying my
grandfather was born in 1872 said that
he would fly if he could keep one foot
on the ground so people got freaked out
but now we all fly mantras are a small
leap yes impaired at getting over I
don't actually when I'm talking to
people that haven't had the experience
I don't refer to them as mantra but the
word mon means mind and trauma means
projection it just means a projection of
the mind what I refer to them as
syllables and sounds that will occupy
the same area in your brain that has got
all these thoughts coming through so if
you if you go ah you can you can
overcome all those little meaningless
thoughts what's the charge it's free
yeah it's beautiful you know what I
heard you said was I knew you were
thinking something I was thinking the
electric chair I know
I was about to give you a sighted
information all right so what have we
learned here we have learned that that
awareness plays a role in the world of
ignorance and the path forward is by
being kind to yourself and consciously
carving out that time for mindful
practice and never attack ignorant front
face front work around the edges and
help to dissolve it because ignorance
may be bliss but it's still ignoring the
what is and if we can make people who
are willfully ignorant feel a slight bit
safer they will become a slight bit less
ignorant they will ignore things a
slight bit less beautiful before we drop
the mic here will you take us out with
another song
[Music]
you know the idea of infinity is hard to
comprehend with our head brain because
infinity is very much a nothingness
because if infinity has anything in it
it can be measured and then it's not
infinite it's just measurable but
infinity is the way things are because
if they weren't they'd have to stop but
then there'd have to be something on the
other end of that stop so infinity is a
reality but it's not one that can be
perceived so it's one that has to be
looked at in what's called faith but
it's not faith in some religious form
it's just faith in the fact that
infinity has to exist it just it's just
the nature of nature because whatever
stops has something on the other side
continuously so this is a little ditty
that I made up with some kids in
[Music]
to be confident Matt be infinite can't
take care of it
we're so fortunate be confident back me
in my bed can take care of it we're so
fortunate to be Canada
[Music]
we'll take good care of it we're so
fortunate
[Music]
so open up your heart let the music
start
open up your voice and rejoice rejoice
let your light shine up the soul
let the good times roll Don said
non-sectarian you know not religious not
anything in any way which is the energy
of life and I call it soul
anyway
Burnett takes good care of it
whistle for
[Music]
all right my friend you are my favorite
mystical magical spiritual core Chester
huh that is exactly what I am yeah
to be continued to be continued all
right I love you guru saying peace peace
plants sot nom nom nom ah stay namaste
blessings grace and be aware in the
ignorance without judging the ignorance
bone phone
[Music]